Good morning, John.
I'm currently in Florida visiting my in-laws,
and, uh, I wanted to introduce you to the
newest member of this little family! This
is Horatio; he's my new zit. Uh, he's a pretty
nice guy. He's actually a bit of a jerk. Say
hi to everybody, Horatio! Hiii!
Ninety nine point nine nine percent of people
right now are thinking like, "Uheeewwww!"
But there is that point zero one percent of
people who, who are named Horatio, who are
just mad at me right now. Sorry, Horatios!
And also everybody else.
Can anybody tell me at what stage in an adult
man's life he stops getting gigantic zits?
Because I've been waiting for that day. For
a long time. And it would be really nice.
Other than that, my life is doing quite well.
I was just visiting friends in Orlando, uh,
and remembering how great high school times
were! I hope that people, uh, anyone, someone
in the world, somewhere, had as much fun with
their friends in high school as I did. I have
to say to those people,: thank you for making
me a more fun, uh, and better person. Silliness
is a vastly under-appreciated quality in humanity.
Uh, I don't know why it is not among our major
virtues. Diligence and kindness and patience
and humility and silliness!
Ahhhhhh what was I gonna talk about? Oh yeah!
I have a message from Hank from the past.
Hank from the past, kick it!
Hello, it is me! From the past! You can tell
because of all the hair. I'm just here to
tell you that this is five-hundred and twelve
dollars that Nerdfighters gave to me for my
birthday, and I'm taking to the bank to deposit
it so that I can donate it to an organization
of my choosing which you will find out shortly.
Also, I'm hoping they'll take the Canadian
money and the Euros. Apa doop-doop-a-doo...
right! To the bank! To the bank! To the bank!
Now I'm going to go get my hair cut. I know;
I'm messing with time today.
So yeah, I got a hair cut. Whaddaya think?
It's a little messy now. I guess messy's in,
though. My dreams of looking like Topher from
Dollhouse every day for the rest of my life
have been squashed, but I'm dealing with it.
You know, every day's a struggle!
So, after I deposited that money and also
did all the calculations to figure out how
much all the foreign money was worth, I came
to the conclusion that I had six-hundred and
thirty-four dollars and twelve cents that
Nerdfighters had given me for my birthday
to donate to a charity of my cau-- A charity
of my cause. Of course. Cause of my choosing.
A charity of my host of... bungy... buns...
But I cannot help but to donate it to water.org
who I went to Haiti with to learn how they
operate and what they do and because I'm such
a fan of the work that water.org does, and
also, because I'm inspired by the charity
of Nerdfighteria, I've decided to double the
amount that you gave me, and I am now giving
that money to water.org. Thank you.
Speaking of which, if you go to my.water.org/vlogbrothers
you can see how Savann Tabak, the community
I visited, is doing on its path to getting
a well. They have formed a well-committee;
they have created a budget for the well; they
have chosen a location and a guard for the
well. I encourage you once again to go and
follow, uh, Savann Tabak at my.water.org and
also, uh, to donate money directly to them.
You don't have to send it to me first. I'm
just gonna give it to water.org anyway.
Just found this, uh, in the corner. Don't
know what's up with him. Is this copyright?
Is this copyright violation? Disney owns him.
Go away, Winnie, go away! You could get me
sued! I'll miss you, Winnie the Pooh.
This one isn't copyrighted, uh, because it's
so scary. Oh, man, you too. I-I've just discovered
a cache of amazingly disfigured and frightening,
uh, antique toys, so I'm gonna go away because
I'm scared for my life.
So Horatio wanted you all to know that he's
doing his best to get rid of this face, so
it can just be him doing the vlogs, but, you
know, you guys can vote which one you think
would be better at this job.
It's not you, okay? Not you!
So, uhhh... [auto-tuned uh-ing] John, I'll
see you on Wednesday!